this morning Democrats are claiming a
significant Election Day prize in
Kentucky State Attorney General Andy
Beshear says he defeated Republican
governor Matt Bevin the race is
officially too close to call but Beshear
leads by about 5,000 votes president
Trump had campaigned for Bevin the night
before the election Democrats also took
control of the Virginia legislature
yesterday promising big changes in that
state ed O'Keefe is covering campaign
2020 for us so ed good morning what are
these results show us well good morning
Tony while Republicans were able to hold
on to the governorship in Mississippi
Tuesday night's other results in state
and local elections show the ongoing
collapse of the Republican Party in the
nation's suburbs that we saw in last
year's elections and while all politics
is ultimately local there's no denying
that President Trump had at least some
effect on the results that could spell
big trouble for him and Republicans
going into the 2020 elections voters in
Kentucky sent a message loud and clear
for everyone to hear Democrat Andy
Beshear claim victory Tuesday night but
Republican governor Matt Bevin wasn't
ready to throw in the towel
we are not conceding this race by any
stretch Bevin ranked this year is one of
the most unpopular governors in the
country amid criticism of his push to
revamp Kentucky's education and Medicaid
policy my wife is a retired teacher he's
trying to take away her insurance
president Trump won Kentucky by 30
points in 2016 and Bevin leaned on him
to help turnout Republicans he's been
incredible at a rally on Monday night
mr. Trump seemed aware that what was at
stake for him and if you lose they going
to say Trump suffered the greatest
defeat in the history of the world this
was the greatest you can't let that
happen to me
in a statement last night the Trump
campaign said the president just about
dragged governor Matt Bevin across the
finish line a final outcome remains to
be seen
despite Bevin Republicans did win every
other statewide race in Kentucky
including Daniel Cameron who became the
first Republican elected Attorney
General in seventy years and the first
african-american to win the job let's
continue continue the success of this
party as we move forward into this next
decade in Virginia where mr. Trump isn't
popular Democrats took full control of
the state legislature
despite scandals this year that engulfed
the top three Democrats in the state one
Democrat who helped them take control as
Shelley Simmons nearly two years ago she
lost after a tie was decided by drawing
a name from a bowl but this time she
soundly beat the incumbent Republican we
can make a change but it takes people
coming out to vote the results in
virginia mean democrats can now try to
pass stricter gun control in the wake of
the mass shooting in virginia beach
earlier this year and in Kentucky
there's no mandatory recount law so the
governor can request counties check
their results but he'd need to win a
courts approval for a full recount all
right ed we're heading into an election
year a presidential election year so
what are Democrats and Republicans
likely to take away from yesterday's
results well look there was something
for everybody Tony the fact that
Republicans won every other race
statewide race in Kentucky and held on
to Mississippi is a good sign but
clearly they're struggling in the
suburbs you look at even local elections
in the Philadelphia suburbs this morning
for example and they're in real trouble
as for the Democrats they'll celebrate
these wins but look at the kind of
Democrat who won moderates who are
pushing middle-of-the-road ideas and
Democrats probably would be wise to
watch in the next year to see how easy
it might be or how hard it could be to
implement those campaign promises like
stricter gun control and raising the
minimum wage all of that could have an
effect of course on whether or not the
Democrats win the presidency in Congress
very interesting in a very fine line ad
thank you very much